vamos a hacer algunos ejemplos de la
creación de gráficas de barras y de
pictogramas el profesor schmidt asignó
un proyecto especial acerca del océano a
sus estudiantes de la materia de
ciencias de la tierra para averiguar si
los estudiantes que pasaron más tiempo
en sus proyectos
sacaron mejores calificaciones les
pregunto a los estudiantes cuánto tiempo
pasaron completando sus proyectos crea
una gráfica de barras para mostrar
cuánto tiempo pasó cada estudiante
completando su proyecto del océano aquí
tenemos la tabla del tiempo que pasó
cada estudiante en su proyecto vamos a
graficar la tenemos aquí que james tardó
36 minutos así que vamos a tomar esta
barrita de james y le vamos a poner en
los 36 minutos en esta marca después
elige
elige paso 54 minutos en su proyecto así
que elige y lo tomamos y lo llevamos
hasta la marca de los 54
después tenemos a 1000 inquietado 36
minutos en su proyecto tomamos a min
link y la dejamos también en la marca de
los 36 minutos después sigue simón con
30 minutos
simón aquí está la levantamos hasta la
marca de los 30 y finalmente quieran que
tardó 12 minutos en su proyecto así que
aquí la levantamos su barrita hasta la
marca de las 12 y con esto hemos hecho
la gráfica que nos piden
vamos a comprobar respuesta es correcta
vamos a hacer otro problema
artur le pregunto a todos los
estudiantes de tercer grado sobre su
actividad favorita después de clases
crea una gráfica de barras para mostrar
cuántas veces se escogió cada actividad
como la favorita de los estudiantes aquí
está la tabla actividad y número de
estudiantes vamos a graficar el club de
español tuvo 40 estudiantes así que club
de español lo elevamos hasta la marca de
los 40 después sigue el club espiritual
que tuvo 56 estudiantes
tomamos esta barrita y la subimos a la
marca de los 56 después sigue el club de
cocina con 24 estudiantes que no es muy
popular por lo que se ve los ritmos a la
marca de los 24 finalmente el club de
arte tiene 64 estudiantes así que
tomamos está y los subimos pues hasta
arriba a la marca de 64 y con esto
tenemos la gráfica
esta información de acá vamos a
comprobar la respuesta
es correcta hagamos otro problema más
una gráfica con imágenes para mostrar el
número de páginas que cada persona ha
leído hasta el momento tenemos aquí a
estas personas y el número de páginas
que cada una leer pero aquí tenemos este
simbolito del libro que nos dice que
esto es igual a 10 páginas leídas bueno
esto es un pictograma crear una gráfica
con imágenes y cada una de estas
imágenes de ese simbolito del libro va a
ser igual a 10 páginas leídas así que yo
tengo aquí a leo en la tabla
me dicen que leo leyó 70 páginas y yo
estaría tentada a poner aquí 70
simbolitos de libros pero recordemos
cada simbolito es igual a 10 páginas así
que vamos a contar lo de 10 en 10
llevamos aquí 10 páginas 20 páginas 30
páginas 40 páginas 50 páginas 60 páginas
y 70 páginas que son
las que leyó lea después hojas y leyó 80
páginas cada simbolito del libro
significa 10 páginas así que tengo que
poner 8 simbolitos en lo que te impongo
un 1 o sea son 10 páginas 20 páginas 30
páginas 40 páginas 50 páginas 60 páginas
70 páginas y 80 páginas ahora veamos
cuánto leyó antoine
antoine leyó 40 páginas así que tenemos
aquí 10 páginas 20 páginas 30 páginas 40
páginas ahora sigue buddy buddy leyó 70
páginas entonces con woody son 10
páginas 20 páginas 30 páginas 40 páginas
50 páginas 60 páginas y 70 páginas
finalmente nicolás cuántas leyó nicolás
50 páginas así que van a ser cinco
símbolos de libros ya que cada dibujo o
cada imagen significa diez páginas
leídas así que son 10 páginas 20 páginas
30 páginas 40 páginas 50 páginas vamos a
verificar nuestra respuesta
es correcta hagamos un problema más
el jugador de baloncesto que anote más
puntos en la temporada ganó un premio de
reconocimiento especial en la escuela
crea una gráfica de dibujos o imágenes
un pictograma para mostrar el número de
puntos que cada jugador anotó en esta
temporada
aquí tenemos cuatro jugadores a mid dina
carolina y antonio y estos son los
puntos que anotó cada quien y aquí nos
fijamos que este símbolo del balón
equivale a ocho puntos entonces vamos a
poner todos los dibujos necesarios para
representar estos puntos quedamos que a
mitad anotó 32 puntos y vamos a contar
de 8 en 8 ya que esta imagen simboliza 8
puntos veamos aquí tengo a mid y si cada
balón simboliza 8 puntos para mí
tendremos 8 16 24 32 que son los puntos
que logró
ahora veamos cuántos anotó digna dina
anotó 64 así que tenemos
8 16 24 32 40 48 56 y 64 muy bien
ahora nos toca carolina cuanto anotó
carolina anotó 40 veamos
8 16 24 38 y 40 muy bien cuanto anotó
antonio veamos
antonio anotó 56 puntos así que son 8
puntos 16 24 32 40 48 y 56 así que ya
tenemos el pictograma o el diagrama de
imágenes de la información que nos
dieron aquí ahora vamos a ver el
resultado es correcto